and we are live we're live yep welcome
back to the weekly pool guys like we
said earlier Robin myself are going to
be here this evening with Stefan Frank
the writer and creator of the book
silver yes for those you guys wondering
what this book is it's the continuation
of the Bram Stoker universe so imagine
bram stoker's dracula universe is still
going on today and what happens if a
thief happens to come across a lot of
the artifacts and gets involved in this
world well you need to read the book to
find out but Rob and I have the honor of
speaking with him today and just go over
a few things now if you guys watched
over my channel you've already seen some
of the questions but we're gonna ask the
same ones because Rob's viewers are
different so you want me to start er um
I guess I guess the first question I
have is do you want to show the book
request yeah it's getting yeah yeah show
the book and kind of give your synopsis
of it that what you like yeah so it's
what you said we'd just a correct one
thing is I actually takes place it's a
continuation of the the Bram Stoker
Dracula universe but it takes place 40
years later so we're in the poke war era
of the 1930s and so yeah so these group
of come in endeavors to steal precious
silver from vampires which is you know
may or may not be survivable idea so
we'll see okay so I guess my first
question I have is it's like what got
you into that idea like what got you
into the idea of like vampires and the
whole you know nor element yeah I mean
you know I think we also things when we
were kids that can I you know marked our
imagination and one of the things that
really inspired me was we there was a
late night movie showing France like
every for where I grew up every Friday
night was like you know at midnight
just go pretty other did you unhook the
phone yes the windows black and white
movies you know that they were showing
and they were like the old 1920s third
not 20s but thirties forties know what
you know black and white movies so you
had monster movies Universal Monsters
right into town bro Tod browning you had
masterpieces under Fritz Lang and you
know movies and stuff like that and also
a B movies in the Nick Carter you know
all that stuff so all that sort of world
in black and white of monsters and
gangsters and and all that stuff kind of
became like this one corner from of my
imagination and I like to think of it as
a world it was a little bit more
innocent and which had more mystery to
it was like pre google map you know i
mean you did there's dark corners of the
world you could still get lost in and
find amazing things and stuff so that
that's kind of you know and it was you
know you had lost cities lost empires
you know supernatural all that stuff
kind of meshed together so that was kind
of like the imaginary world that I'm I
wanted to connect with with silver and
so and what I love about you know
gangsters you know con man vs vampires
is that when you think of it come in and
vampires are fairly similar you know
because they are predatory in nature the
whole or on the outskirts of society
they're creatures of the night they
cannot yeah so they fray on you and
sorry and also there's nothing you know
they're like either figuratively or
literally so less like they don't engage
in life and what it is to be alive
productive you know condom don't have
families and stuff I don't have those
relationships so they are dead inside in
a way so between the dead inside and in
the living dead there's like a
connection there so we have this guy
who's this this is this con man this you
know and who's letting his life in a way
that you know as you read runs you to
the Real Living Dead
going to be led to questioning the
meaning of being alive like that feeling
well what is it that makes you feel like
you're living your life yeah see to me
that's that's a really cool concept
because like more often than not when
you watched like these Dracula films
with the exception of maybe like
Nosferatu which was really more of a hey
here's just a really creepy looking
Dracula but like when you watch a lot of
those Dracula film that's usually some
kind of romance thing like when you go
back and watch like Bram Stoker's
Dracula you know with Gary Oldman it's
basically just like a romance yeah thing
you know and I think it's cool like when
you take the romantic element away and
it's not really Dracula like pursuing a
woman so much as it is like people are
trying to dupe him and in a lot of ways
Dracula's the same way like he really
kind of leads women into vulnerable
situations and then like feeds on me
absolutely and you know you know and
it's just because that that's also why I
have this motif of silver because you
people been asking me why silver and was
that mean and stuff in this universe and
of course silver is the thing that can
kill vampires but it's also the thing
that you know burns them and you know
what makes them feel you know how
mortality is that's why people smoke
people you know you know sky job but you
know we're you know what kills you
serpents you feel alive you know a
little bit and so I think in my story
the vampires are living that they're not
like the romantic sort of like you know
they are the Living Dead and so they're
they're empty inside and they are trying
to recapture our some of them completely
embrace the darkness and the emptiness
and the knee elastic sort of approach to
their in life he will and not to give
away value to see that Dracula himself
is like between those two world because
his head Mina Harker and stuff like that
so he's the one vampire that could go
either way you know that that you know
is still flirting with this idea of
maybe maybe there's this light left in
him that there may be your life there
may be meaning there may be emotions you
know so and we'll see which are we
you know cuz it's a tragic figure so you
can keep going I'm actually excited to
see what's gonna happen in volume 2 i'm
awful just go ahead and spoil it all man
just just spoil it off stuff myself yeah
yeah yeah one thing that i wanted to
mention is for the viewers who aren't
aware but you also were the director if
I got that my facts correctly but you
did a our giant you did the I was not
the director of The Iron Giant however I
was a supervising animator on the
Alliance which means I was supervising a
whole group of animators and different
sequences in the movie right yep there
you go and you also did a despicable me
and you've done the Smurfs the actual 3d
movie one right yeah so I did work in
this tickle me I did story on stickam
look at so i had a clear to make sure
another you write about the smurfs but
the the one that I directed was a 80
special customer us MERS a legend of
smurfy hollow which is really exciting
because it had a little bit of CG Smurfs
from you know they were like the same
stitch is merciless you seen movie and
then it was a halloween thing so that
gets they lost in the woods and you know
this start telling this ghost story and
as detail at ghost story we going to the
story in the story and that becomes 2d
animation and I was really exciting for
me because I used to be two gamer as you
mentioned with the iron giant but also
you know I felt like the disperse which
I grew up with reading those books when
I was a kid you know never really got
there doing to the animation because the
TV serie was nice and everything but it
was not exactly the golden days of
animation you know and I felt like they
had so with this we r sports we're able
to get like a really great team of a
two-game meters and is my guys and stuff
and so we really enemy forces like the
first time that you would really see
the smurfs into the animation animated
of the future quality animation can a
disney level and he's redoing justice to
the characters to the themes of who they
are stuff like that and it's i have to
say that that's been really really fun
project to do and also it's been super
well received and people have been
really read you know digging it I get a
great nomination for it for Best
Director rolla and but you know and it's
it was really fun to revisit to the
animation and to really do a Smurfs just
is that way the question I was actually
getting at with it with the the projects
you have worked on is coming from that
what what made you decide to go from you
know Iron Giant Smurfs despicable me 2
doing comic books having your own comic
book your own creator own project
instead of I'm assuming you have enough
resources to kind of get into the you
know at least make the bigger guys aware
of it but to make this your own to make
a creator-owned project that is yours
yeah putting out there well you know you
know coming swear my first love you know
my parents have they worried dinner you
know they had a store in France that you
know the books comics art supplies a
whole bunch of stuff so I grew up with
an interesting thing too is that Marion
comics weren't redistributed in France
until like the mid 70s you know and then
to the old came out I want so when I
significant like in the you know late
seventies you know then everything came
out at once so we you had the Golden Age
comics the Silver Age the Bronze Age was
in full swing so on the same newsstand
you know on the same rack you had like
the Kirby stuff from I know I got a dead
behind you could show you the french
edition of like the Galactus you know so
you had that been coming out at the same
time as you had like Gwen Stacy and yeah
you know it's like it was all coming out
together so you had this sort of like
you know you're like those theories
where there's no time and everyone is
the multiverse is that would be then
actually be pretty awesome just like
walking I mean you see that kind of
stuff at comic-con that's so like like
as a kid to walk in and they're like hey
guys we have
mix and to see like basically you're
catching up on on you know 40 years
worth of comics you know in like in a
single store in one day would be awesome
but so so here's my question so I always
imagined that when it came to like doing
animations you know and all I kind of
some of course that would be something
that would tie in directly into comics
but with the idea of like working on
animations the idea of actually like
making movies and things like that I
always thought that when it came to
animators that it was more or less like
a big party as a movie was being made
you guys are like ordering pizza and
drawing stuff up and like I mean you
guys have like the boards with the oh
really well no you know animation is uh
it's very rewarding because when you see
your your your scene come alive on the
screen you know your carrot your your
drawings you know come to life and
there's something really magical about
it and in fact that's that's how i got
into animation which is that you know as
you get other thing you know i was
drawing comics and I quickly realize
that hey you can make them move and
stuff like that and then I saw the movie
heavy metal yeah I've seen heavy metal
lishus this is like right you know
because it was the perfect combination
and but the thing is that's not what the
initial industry really does you know
and so it's a little bit ago going back
to do it which were saying animation is
kind of its it's a life project ready
and that's why only now am i coming back
into comics because for the longest time
you know English again it takes
everything over because when you think
of it when you're an animator you're an
actor the pencil so into you need to
because people only go see movies to see
joints they wanna see if we realize
characters so you know you need to
develop your acting sense and your
acting chops so that you can actually
act the scene right but at the same time
you have to be able to draw it without
having any drawing limitations because
you don't want to be trying to like make
an acting choice and oh I can't I
don't
draw that if I can do that you can't
have that limitation right and it's and
it's drawing but it's also your
understanding of motion analysis because
nothing pulls you out of a scene quicker
than like a weird movement like a walk
that's funny or something like you know
hey so you're all those layers I mean
especially I think now it's broken Ella
but it's different in CG with CG
animation but in when I worked as an
animator into the animation there was so
many layers so many walls you had to
climb before you could get to actually
expressing yourself with the art form
that it was a lot of work a lot of long
hours a lot of tears and blood and very
rewarding in the end but really tough
commitment so I mean you know like you
said I'm sure it is it's it's
unbelievable Ike when you sit down you
watch a movie you know and you say like
like my work went into the creation of
this movie but when you're making a
comic like when you were sitting down
you were making silver like looking at a
silver screen and watching a movie play
out like that's that's one side of the
coin like obviously you how about the
voice actors on the other side that are
bringing the drawings to life and making
the characters like so then people can
relate to you but with silver like you
have absolute total control yeah so like
how does that compare to like being an
animator and actually like drawing you
know characters that show up in movies
and that kind of thing yeah I mean it's
I mean the creative process indeed is
completely I mean couldn't be more
different you know I mean when you're
make when you make a movie you know
you're basically you know spending a lot
of other people's money you know magic
as you notice everybody knows how much
you know micromanagement and you know
how much I don't even mean this in a
negative way you know I just mean that
there's so much at stake that every move
is you know so you know it involves so
in terms of the creative environment you
you have to take into account a lot of
different people and their needs which
are you know the reason why this baby is
getting late so you have to respect that
and then also because of the the way
those movies are
red you know you're working with
hundreds if not thousands of people so
there's a it's like when directing a
movie it's like my day is one giant
meeting you know anywhere i basically
meet with you know when artists when you
know anyway for work from the actors to
anyway you know people from person to
person just kind of constantly reaching
the vision and how it applies to this
particular moment and stuff like that so
that that's really completely an
external you know thing and whereas when
you're drawing the book it's completely
internal you don't need to explain just
like you need to talk to anybody you
just do it you know and so is that i
guess that that's where we're really any
of course yes you're the autonomy of a
it's my own money to my own project i
can do whether i want you know and
that's great but it's really that the
difference when one side of the coin you
know it's me trying to explain to other
people what i like them to do and let
them surprise me with great stuff and
you know what I'm doing the comics I
don't even need to talk to anybody it's
just me doing it so from those two yeah
completely different life uh as a life
experience thing you're mean is just as
you're living it it could not be more of
a different zone yeah yeah I would think
it would be I think it'd be kind of
surreal at first because like when
you're an animator like the company
comes to you and says like animate this
movie like make this character react
this way I mean I don't know if I don't
know what comes first it's like the
animation well I imagine it's the
animation and the person voice is the
animation but like like you're basically
like more less being told what to do
like you're being told like make this
character this way make you make him act
this way like this is how he's supposed
to be so you know with like you know the
iron giant I mean you're talking about a
character that like the the giant
himself which you know if i recall
doesn't if i recall correctly doesn't
really speak and so like everything he
says is communicated through his actions
and so which one hundred percent
animation to communicate the character
but when you sit down
and and you have this comic book like
the entire story is created by you the
animation like the design is created
like like the entire concept for this
comic book so rather than being in a
circumstance where you say like I'm just
doing half of this like you say like I'm
doing the whole nine yards I've got the
whole lot the whole thing so the person
that sits down to read this comic like
has to know exactly what this comic is
about where it's going and what the
purpose of it is and like it's all in
your hands that's right and you know the
thing is it's it's a lot of time to you
know so it's like sometimes it feels
like and especially like now that the
books you know coming out and I've
already sold like a whole lot of armor
congresso I already had the reaction so
I know that it connects and it makes
sense and stuff but like what I was just
like okay I'm just gonna do this you
know and you do this long enough that
you start to feel like you're Jack
Nicholson in the shining yeah and you're
like okay I'm actually doing something
that makes sense here or mind just some
crazy person in my office you know me
know and really until so you have those
but you just have to sort of have the
faith do we just like this just
believing your own guts you know stick
with your guns yeah Beijing I remember
the same problem with half the stuff I
make I'm going through the whole time
I'm creating this stuff for YouTube I'm
sitting there like this isn't gonna make
any sense no one's gonna understand what
I'm doing it makes sense to me but no
one's gonna get it yeah you get to the
ending you know like oh hey work j/o so
in the book silver we have two main
characters yet Finnegan and we have
sledge yeah uh did you now Finnegan's
more of your kind of jokey thief but he
takes everything on a serious kind of
manner at this at one time and sludge is
more she's like hardened by everything
that's gone on she's the girl with the
katana she's the one that makes the
majority of the awesome kills um so were
they based on anyone do you know a girl
who's harden it has a katana and a joke
this thing man wow he actually owns a
katana
vampires uh he's gonna would too so he's
gonna kill you know you know short of
silver this is the best friend there she
haven't straighten his heart man you
know uh yeah it's it's interesting um I
don't know that she's based literally on
somebody that I know I think there's a
like for me when I you know whenever I
write something it'll always kind of
borrows to some of the things that are
going on you know in my life you know I
mean like if there's kids involved it's
you know some of the relates somehow
doubt to the experience of a you know
you know where my kids are what stage
they're at and what's going on with them
and stuff for thin I think that there's
there's a theme that I'm very fond off
personally and so I'm very interested
myself in the fourth for my you know
life story you know you know father's
the theme the theme of fathers can
always you know is important to me and I
think that a lot of stories most stories
if not all stories when you think of
them really are about you know your your
forefathers literally or a societal
level which ever you know which leopard
one way or the other your forefathers
have achieved greatness and or you know
the horrible things and the question for
you as the new hero is a you know how do
you either live up to the you know live
live up to the greatness or live down
the sins you know I mean and and I think
that's you know he from you know Luke
Skywalker to you know like Star Trek you
know in the new Star Trek you know like
you know any Kirk your dad was only
captain for eight minutes but in eight
minutes it was the you know the greatest
captain we've ever seen now live up to
that you know so then um
I think there's the thing will find with
with Finn as we get deeper into the
character and I want to spoil it but in
it somehow is the same with her is that
those are people who somehow the chain
of knowing had to be an adult help you a
person had to live your life and engage
young somehow something happened and
that transmission has been broken and
their people whose you know therefore
doing engage with other people you know
she finds it easier to take care of the
Living Dead you know and he finds it
easier to always had an angle not really
come at you straight well there's always
an angle it's it's a different night sir
so what you see as those characters
greatest strength as often interviewing
with people or in real life or
literature is also the symptom of their
brokenness you know so for him it's a
new and I again almost played to the war
but that's because if you want those two
people are they are broken people who
have not learned somehow the
transmission of what it is to be like a
person somehow get broken didn't get
passed on something happened and now
that you know and you know in story you
always have the wine now moment and
they're all coming to a point where yeah
you're they're gonna try to do this
thing and lost oya wait it is but
there's this job that they're trying to
pull but also they're all coming to a
point in their lives where you know
they've learned whichever bridges we're
left to burn now it's just like it's
also coming out different than the way
you came in because that world can
elites know where you know yeah I'm
gonna ask one of the quad we have two
questions a really good question that
came across from viewers right now great
um someone asked those real quick but uh
crazy comics would like to know if
they're any comics that were your
favorite and any comics that you would
wish you a neighbor that would you wish
were yours yeah so um going back to to
when I was a kid a pretty you know Kirby
I mean there was different in American
comics especially there was a Jack Kirby
was just like I mean what a
nine-year-old hasn't had their mind just
blown by the sanity of manpower and the
mythic and in fact I'm really trying you
know because what I'm doing with this
story right is that it's got the
original Bram Stoker Dracula thing at
the core and I'm extending it in every
possible direction right and so and so
including in the past adding some
mythology to so we go actually back to
the Bronze Age right and so what I'm
doing those things I'm thinking Kirby
Kirby and what I try to do in those
moments is like the last thing I want to
do is try to open a Kirby both because
if I did and it would overwhelm me and
you know so I'm just trying to connect
with the memory of a you know I remember
it from I was a kid or like how like
whatever page made me feel and I'm
trying to kind of channel that and can I
recapture that and then why do my fish
than what I've done I go check out the
pigeon question oh it's completely
different but it's okay it's just like
the spirit of it I tried I can I
reconnect you so Kirby is one my other
you huge influence was Will Eisner uh
you know after i saw heavy metal as a
kid you know I was like you know what
I'm gonna make my own animated movie i
came home and basically the following
four years i made this short film of the
spirit you know which you know all
showing you know super 8 you know but
you know with animation yeah you know
sales and individually a 90-minute film
right and so yeah there's a lot of Will
Eisner at least in in aspiration in what
I do okay oh and the other question was
from I lost the other person who acid
here Lewis Andrews wants to know and we
are on the Marvel explain channel so
it's kind of a warranted question but he
wants to know what your favorite Marvel
artists of all time was and then
actually gonna lead to my art of my
question about the artwork gets and
silver alright so i already mentioned
curvy and that of course was you know
but it is to more than f2 to mention one
is gene colan whose art look dangerous
me when I was a kid you know Brooks for
grown-ups it's it's it's you know who it
was scary right so I loved it but also
general mera senior you know because
because he did you know the spider-man
you know run you know like the whole
Quinn station all I said you know that
mate I was just at the right age to and
again I don't think I came out again you
came out in front of two years later
than he did in the state so it was not
you for you guys like that it was new
for me you know and then he came out and
he's just like I I mean I always say you
know I had to because you know it's
wrenching when you talk about
superheroes right it's like when I think
of superheroes I think I like to think
of them from like the time where they
met the most in my life where you know
still happen and it was not very easy
for me and uh at some point when I was
like ten years old super here eight nine
ten superheroes meant everything to me
and so I had basically to Tennessee's
one was that you know you know I it was
you know at night i'm falling asleep
right there's just snuck in my window
and there's like either Superman or
Batman and they're like hey kid you know
Joker he got me real bad can I come in
you know come in yeah and then you know
of course um um you know I have read the
next issue so hey you don't look out for
this or that because this is where the
thing is you're not and then it would
come to my school that makes their for
showing show-and-tell and then this is
my friend Batman you know so I had like
the father figure superheroes that's
very like more like the DC characters
for me but the Marvel stuff was more
like you know I'd be like at the school
cafeteria kind of like daydreaming and
bored out of my mind you know I this
drain that you know like some terrorists
with a tag to school you know leaving me
no choice but to reveal to everybody
that in fact mmm Marvel was more that
was like SD she would one of the father
figures that I could sort of like MOOC
up too and you know like the egg
and the you know the you know Johnny
Storm you know Peter Parker or less that
that's the that's the snow speaking to
me most directly that makes any sense
yeah she makes perfect sense the most
directly yeah i mean i was thinking was
this because you said France got it
later than the US and it must have been
fine back then because like if that
happened nowadays everything would have
been spoiled by the internet and Twitter
yeah like the man said yes the comic
would have been out for a day and it
just put it's like you did yall with the
gwen stacy death and they didn't bring
that over with it ya know it was and you
know it's interesting because friends
had this as in many european countries
they don't pull out they don't put out a
like the single floppies so you know
what they do is they have those trades
that are not full quality trade so
they're still in the quality of floppies
with their trays and the track three or
four or five titles so you would get the
de Marville book and every every month
you have a daredevil and x-men
spider-man and Iron Man and you know
stuff like that I'd be much tougher for
me yeah yeah definitely cheaper yeah it
was cheaper and it was interesting I so
you probably give another question no I
mean I was just um it's it's it's I
think the people i think that when
people start reading comics like they I
think they latch on to the comics they
first started with but I think for more
people it's more of like a generational
thing like for me comic books in the 90s
is where it was that like comic book
characters in the 1990s the x factor
x-men stuff like that like that you know
fantastic for that was like to me that
will always be the best era of comic
books for me because like that was when
I was first introduced to it and I was
just so captivated by the idea of comic
books like when I was able to first
really go out buy them read them things
like that is when I was just so
captivated by him and it seems to be the
same way for you you know you know when
you were a kid like you know you have
these experiences that just latched you
on the comic books you know it's
interesting because like sometimes I
mean a movie theater and I'm looking and
I'm watching a movie you know and I'm
like
I don't know how I feel about this you
know and then I have to tell myself yeah
but how would I have with you I felt you
know when you know you were 12 or 13 or
15 and they're like oh my god and just
like so I think you have to face the
fact as you get older nothing's gonna
hit you as strong you know when you're
30 then something's gonna hit you when
you're when you're 12 is the fact of
life you know yeah it's a sad fact of
life it is but uh as we're going on to
the the the kind of link that we decided
to set aside for this I didn't want to
ask a final question which is one of
those from Bravo you got anything um but
going back through your book here on the
silver book towards the back of the the
trade you actually a few different
variant art styles from a couple of the
people and the big question I want to
ask is what made you decide to settle on
the one that you went with because it's
kind of like I like it it's like a
minimalistic footed to see it it's like
so it's almost like a two-tone kind of
art style which really really actually
shows quite a bit that happens in the
panel but seeing the variance in the
back it's like well it could have looked
like this they could it look like this
yeah yeah what made you decide to
finalize the one that you decided to go
with ya the style that for me because I
was trans I was saying before I was
trying to connect with the you know the
the the black-and-white movies you know
and I was talking by Will Eisner you
know and I was thinking you know like if
you look at the artist edition ki
baratan just shake it off like this is
like the book that changed my life I'll
show you right now I the french edition
of the Spirit I know if you can see but
it's like it's a big format it's like if
it was in the newspaper yeah and look at
the oh it's really cool does I don't
know how much you can see on skype but
you know there's it this kind of more
thing yeah yeah and that's exactly the
feel that way to recapture you know so
when you think of you know movies like
you know from the 1933 King Kong or you
know to to the Will Eisner pages and
that feeling of like adventure stuff
like the Milton Caniff and and stuff
that
that's really what can I drove my visual
inspiration for how to draw the book
yeah yeah okay I mean I really like the
direction you went with it it looked it
looks as its I've never seen anything
really in that manner i mean i've read i
read on quite a few would vary Xindi
books and they all everyone tries to get
their own style but those were like i
was able to tell what was going on I
felt it because the problem having a lot
of indie books is too much is going on
on a panel they're trying to give their
own unique style and they go too much in
that direction I just get lost as to
what's going on I don't follow it
anymore yeah well you know it's that's a
good point and that's where the it's my
I guess my cinematic background because
I worked on I don't know 25 movie
something like that you know so the way
I'm letting out this book is the same
way I'm pouring a sequence for a movie
so it's it's like you know it's very and
everything and so hopefully out of
clarity comes impact and impact gives
you also emotional impact but it's like
to me it's i'm using the same rules that
I use when I you know putting together a
movie sequence that I'm when putting
together a comic page and the thing is I
don't also give people the impression
that it's an old-fashioned book no it's
like the it's not a throwback it's
completely modern and that's what I like
about that styles like in the postmodern
can away you can there there's an
innocence to it but so it's like yes it
is that stuff but with like a very
cinematic as I was saying approach and
and also also sense of standardization
that it is a little bit modern i mean i
have to say people a lot of your cell
your stupid might have me no answer
which I take as a huge compliment achill
i think is an amazing amazing amazing
artist but i've always been attracted to
like the you know like the Mignola the
shaking the kirby in a well so you know
people who don't just draw well but it's
that combination of a drawing that it
you know has chops with a certain sense
of style ization and an abstract you
know so
it's it's old and new is traditional in
many ways and but very modern and
radical in other ways yeah okay um well
now that we've kind of comes to the
closed at the time length we really want
to put towards this could you hold up
your book for a second there seven um so
if you guys are wondering what book
reason hold on a second house you gonna
wait for it cuz we can hear it quite
well I want to get over there oh ok ok
guys if you're interested in the book
we've been talking about the
continuation of the bram stoker universe
in a 1940's noir I did have that wrong
any opening when I said it was modern
day um it is a really great book we did
have the honor of reading it early and
it comes out November 12 if I have my
date correct this time correct so that
is next wednesday and or anybody who's
in the LA area we're going to do a
release signing party at meltdown comics
on Sunset Boulevard Wednesday the 12 at
7pm so it's too bad that we won't be
there cuz I would love to go to LA for
that yeah well yeah if you guys are
interested just go to your local comic
book story and just like with many indie
books they may not be ordering this
ahead of time so you need to personally
request this hey I really want to read
the silver book could you get it to get
it on order for me get it on my list get
about my weekly poll so um is there
anything else you want to add before we
close out on this devin no I was
pleasure chatting with you guys um yeah
I mean so I'll just say people can go to
a dark planet comics which is the
publishing company which is my
publishing company that i started with
silver and there's a lot more than about
to do so it's going to be so keep that
thing in mind dark planet comics i'm
gonna be giving the link to that develop
you go yeah yeah below yeah and i say
we're also linking to there's a really
fun trailer for the book on youtube
which i think you can get to just from
the link you are using the other day you
know it's a refund video it gives you a
good sense of the girl gets you pumped
up want to read the book i think yeah
guys and and also be aware that Stefan's
twitter account is in the description so
you guys can follow him on twitter for
updates on silver and any other
Jack city has going on but um with that
being said I do want to say thank you
Stefan for coming out and talking with
us and it was a real honor to speak to
you on me like I said earlier the iron
giant really it's just like I used to
watch with my dad and something I
remember well and and reading the book
was a great i like when you guys said
that over to me i really i really do
appreciate that that was really it was a
really good read oh great thank you yep
alright guys we're gonna go ahead and
call the night and yeah we'll catch you
guys later Oh Thursday with the regular
show and maybe we'll have some more
people were justtlike yep peace